i need a color photograph of george
washington i'm looking for a globe of
the earth isn't there a life-size one
i'm looking for a list of laws i can
break
that would send me back to jail for a
couple of months
good morning nick good morning mr
goodson it must be really nice to have a
job where you get to
sit around and read all day it's all
drunks and crazy people
you're gonna have to put your clothes
back on are you gonna do something about
this cause he's kind of ruining the song
for me
[Music]
the homeless man was found dead outside
the public library when it gets this
cold
i don't know why they don't just let us
stay here mr gustaf i got to talk to you
there's not enough shelter for us people
on the street
who is us
we can all come stay at your place there
are a lot of cop cars
is everything all right patrons are
staging in action the library has not
been sanctioned an official
emergency shelter
so now is probably not a great time to
come and get my library card
so come on bring this guy
this is detective bill ramstein sooner
or later you're gonna have to open that
door
they're not coming out of there unless
we make
me i am not prepared to be in a standoff
with a cop you're the one who's always
like vive la resistance
this is bigger than riding the metro and
getting organic food
we're a public library not a shelter for
the homeless why do all this
for what let them know that we still
matter
[Music]
use it to get some food maybe a room
you're gonna offer me money and then
tell me what to do with
it how do you know what i need
why don't you just hand the phone to the
guy that's doing all the talking
i don't want to talk to the police
[Music]